I want to take a minute here to insert
some factual basis into the
disinformation that is being spread very
quickly about Donald Trump's supposedly
brilliant economy and today I'm not
going to argue with you about economic
lag times and when you attribute an
economy to one president versus the
previous versus the next not going to
argue about whether the stock market is
a good indicator of how the economy is
doing overall it's not we've talked
about that before that's just not
today's topic today the topic is simply
to compare Obama and Trump on three
metrics the stock market jobs and income
first let's do income since we have new
data there since Donald Trump took
office income growth has slowed down
compared to the Obama administration
incomes grew 5.8 percent from 2014 to
2016 under Barack Obama and then when
Donald Trump took over from 2016 to 2018
incomes grew at about half of that rate
now why don't we have 2019 data yet well
it's not a trick people's taxes just
haven't been done yet Pete taxes aren't
due until April 15th or even October if
you take the extension so we just don't
have the 2019 data yet next let's look
at the stock market looking at the S&P
500 the broadest of the three major
indices you will see that the S&P 500
gained more than 60 percent during
Barack Obama's first 37 months that's
how long Trump's been president so we're
comparing first 37 months of each
presidency you would have gained 60% in
the S&P 500
during Barack Obama's first three years
plus one month while the S&P 500 has
gained only 37 percent during Donald
Trump's first three years plus one month
and then lastly on jobs if you we did
this in its own segment not long ago the
last three years of Obama's presidency
saw more than eight million jobs created
whereas the first three years of Trump's
saw almost 20% smaller job growth only
six point six million jobs create
that is per the Bureau of Labor
Statistics so when you put it all
together
Obama was better on income growth income
growth has slowed since Trump became
President Obama was better on the stock
market when we compared Trump's of full
presidency so far that the equivalent
time period under Barack Obama and
Barack Obama was better on job creation
was it that the recovery that Barack
Obama was overseeing was solely
responsible for this well that wouldn't
really explain the job growth at the end
of Barack Obama's presidency so what you
have to understand here is I am NOT
giving you this information to tell you
that there's nothing good happening in
Trump's economy there are people who
have done well in Trump's economy
there's no question there are indicators
that look okay in Trump's economy and I
am not telling you this to pretend that
everything about Barack Obama's economy
was gingersnaps and water falls when we
look at different indicators we get
different results and for a lot of
people the economy hasn't been good
under Trump and it wasn't good under
Barack Obama the point is when they pick
the metrics to hang their hats on and we
look at those metrics and see that Trump
is underperforming Obama you have to see
the brazen and deceptive nature of what
they are trying to sell you the
disinformation propaganda I'm glad to
debate how do we really tell how an
economy is doing and it requires more
than three metrics that's for sure and
we've talked about that before but what
we can't allow is not just for them to
set the narrative it's bad enough when
they set the narrative but to set the
narrative based on misleading facts or
things that are not actually factual
that's the point of showing you this
information today I tweeted an image
summarizing all of this yesterday to my
Twitter page D Pakman it's been
retweeted a lot and we're doing
everything we can to spread that these
are the numbers and the numbers don't
tell us anything it's sort of like if
you accept that climate change is
happening that doesn't tell us what we
have to do and what the policies should
be but if we have people who are still
spreading denial
conspiracy theories about climate change
we're not even going to be able to have
the conversation about what should be
done
recognizing that stock growth has been
slower under Trump recognizing that job
growth has been been lower under Trump
it doesn't tell us what has to happen
but we're starting with the facts and
that's where we should always be
starting privacy calm is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you $5.00
just for using their free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman privacy's of
service I've been using for a while now
I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works when you pay for something online
or over the phone instead of exposing
your real credit card number privacy
lets you generate virtual card numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman